greets everyone I'm Alana and welcome to
my channel today i have a sort of job
update well not technically a job update
my job is saying the same i'll still be
making all of the same content that I
normally make on IG and I'm just kind of
adding a job on top of my job but
seriously I'm going to be hosting IGN's
daily news show the daily fix there are
a couple of reasons I wanted to talk
about this one is to tell you guys how
you can watch it two is why I'm doing it
because for over a year now people have
been asking me if I do the fix and I've
always thought no until this kind of
circumstance came around and I
reconsidered it and three is also just
cuz I wanted to explain but anyone who
doesn't watch the stuff that I do on IGN
what my job actually is cuz right now
I'm making a lot of stuff and IGN
basically lets me make whatever I want I
don't have anyone who was like hey I
wanna make this video if you see a video
on IGN that I am in or that I have a
writing credit on or anything like that
it's because I wanted to do it and IGN
is really cool about that so the first
point um you can watch the daily fix on
IGN every day I'm also going to add
every episode to the news playlist on my
own YouTube so if you're not into IGN
you can still watch it here if you like
and the reason I'm excited about it is
really that I'm planning to sort of take
something that has existed on IGN for I
don't know a lot of years originally and
hosted by Jessica Chobot they don't be
asleep Naomi Kyle and I'm gonna try and
just inject a lot of my personality into
it there are totally restrictions on how
much I can do this but I'm gonna try and
be just creative and fun with this show
and I would love for you guys to tell me
if you like it I want people to watch it
and tell me what they think of this new
version of the show so can be a dramatic
change it's just like a little few
things that I want to do differently
which brings me to my second point which
is people that asked me if I wanted to
do the daily fix and for a while I had
said no with Naomi hosting it it was
totally Naomi's show and she is an
excellent human who I think like did
that perfectly or her style and I
wouldn't want to just come up someone
else's style of that show
and I think it made sense for me to do
an episode and how to do an episode
because I would effectively be trying to
replicate haha so now the way this kind
of came about was the producers of the
show found out that Naomi was going to
be leaving and asked if I would be
interested in doing it I hadn't really
thought about it at all I didn't expect
that they would ask me because I knew
that the higher-ups at IGN wouldn't ask
me I've seen comments people being like
as soon as Naomi leaves gonna ask me to
do the daily fix that's not how this
happened
the producers of that show asked me if I
would be interested in doing it and I
said only if I could make changes to it
and I kind of saw the thinking about it
and I just like got excited about the
idea of having the opportunity to do
that - I guess refresh something that's
been on agian for a really long time in
a very similar format so I think they
announced that Naomi was leaving and I
found out that my manager didn't want me
to do it which kind of came up in those
discussions so I reached out to him and
was like hey I'm in Canada right now so
we can't be having these discussions in
person but I kind of just wanted to say
so that no one else speaks for me that I
would be willing to do this if I could
change it so then that was like told to
someone else he was like okay we're okay
with this and then they just wanted to
talk to me about what those changes were
exactly but ultimately I am looking at
it from the perspective of a producer we
have a show that's existed for a while
but I just want to put more personality
and I think editorial opinion into and
see how it goes maybe I hate it and I
host it for six months and then I stop
but at the very least I just kind of
want to evolve that product basically
and that's exciting to me they were
going to have the three male hosts just
rotate between each other while they did
like a search to find someone else so
again I want to say this wasn't
something that they were just like Ilana
you do this so that brings me to my next
point what do I actually do it IGN but
anyone who doesn't watch those videos or
like it doesn't pay attention IG and I
thought I would just kind of tell you
what my job actually is I am a producer
I was hired as a writer and then
ultimately recognized the value of
having a producer skill set so wanted to
start doing that more often what being a
producer in this role actually means is
coming up with
something whether it's a series or just
a one-off video and then seeing it be
executed for example last week we had
the Paris games week conference I had to
go to an event I asked our host max if
he could write a script about his
opinions on the loss of his pop didn't
ask him what opinion to give was just
kind of like I want to know what your
opinion on this is he wrote a script I
edited the hell out of that script I
submitted a request to basically our
video system to make sure it would get
filmed it was filmed I requested out for
the thumbnail I worked on the headline
and then I worked on making a written
version of it alongside Max and like
really fleshing that out I oversaw the
Edit I asked the editor to make changes
to the video and then we publish it I
host two weekly podcasts a Playstation
and our xbox show I'm not on all of them
every week but that is a big part of my
job there's a lot about live streams I
hosted the one for Paris games week but
I also just do like actual game play
live streams pretty often I don't
necessarily know what I'm going to do
those until like the day before
sometimes but I do do this quite a bit I
have a science segment that we've just
kind of started off to try and get off
the ground for like two months now on
our weekly talk show up at noon where I
just talk about science stuff very
excited about that one it's like it just
any excuse to me to talk about science
and it's great I produce two Let's Plays
a week for the PlayStation and Xbox
channels that we have which is
youtube.com slash IGMP on for the
PlayStation one and you should come
watch our channel locked for the Xbox
one again that means I come up with what
game we play I come up with who plays
the game I make sure that it's scheduled
and make sure the Edit gets done for the
beyond ones I edit all of them as well
and I just want to say I'm very proud of
those videos we record for an hour it
usually takes me three times the length
of the video to edit so those videos in
theory take four hours to make and I
make them every week and I edit from an
hour down to like 12 minutes and I edit
like dumb photoshop's into there and
stupid music I just
I'm very very proud of those videos
everyone I first started doing them
someone would be like ooh Alana's gonna
be mad about that at it because I do
like a zoom on my face looking very
unattractive and be like actually I was
the one who edited this and I produce a
weekly a Q&A segment on the PlayStation
channel as well which is called
rapid-fire but that's basically just my
excuse of trying to get an IGN off-topic
podcast launched I've been wanting to do
that since I started and this is like
the perfect way to do it I also
sometimes help to write news and I still
try to put together cosplay galleries
when I can I also orchestrate pretty
much all of our unboxings meaning that I
get the product I unbox a lot of the
product but for the most part it's like
me talking to piada like get these
things in sometimes we put them on up at
noon and then I also do a lot of our
events coverage so I go to a lot of PAX
East PSX those are a lot of previews a
lot of like convo videos which are like
kind of quick conversational preview
stuff and I do actual formal previews at
preview events and reviews as well
basically I do a lot of stuff and IGN is
really great about letting me do
whatever I want to so that's my job
right now and that could change
dramatically in a year the daily fix is
going to like readjust some of my duties
and maybe I won't be able to do some of
the other things that I'm doing I'm now
producing God knows how many videos a
week how many is it a 10 maybe more and
then I do one a week on patreon what are
we gonna hear I'm making a lot of stuff
but this is kind of what I live for
but maybe I'll do a day-in-the-life up
flow to show you guys like what an
average day for me is like as at this
stage I'm at a point where I don't have
time for lunch breaks and I like we
often get to 4 p.m. and if not eaten and
I pretty much can't leave before 7 p.m.
I'm like it's pretty hectic but I really
enjoy what I'm doing
so I guess that's it for this video I
just yeah I wanted to give you guys an
update on what I'm doing I know there
are some people who have subscribed to
my channel though like wait you what
could i GN like they didn't even know
and just that I'm excited about the
daily fix it was something I didn't see
myself ever doing but I just saw this as
an opportunity more than anything to
have an impact on
thing that I guess has been like kind of
a staple it's gonna be real dumb I have
dumb things planned I hope it ends up
being funny but that is pretty much it
for me today
you guys huge thanks to everyone whose
names are on screen right now for their
support on patreon you are the reason
that I can get away with keeping this
YouTube channel running when YouTube
stopped supporting it at all alrighty
you guys I'm Alana and I will see you
guys next time no way